and now it begins
No
now attends what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for the final
Game of Thrones Season eight plot leaked
video today I will be reading season 8
episode 6 and this one looks like it's
not as detailed as some of the other
episodes there isn't as much dialogue
between the characters and there doesn't
seem to be as many scenes but I'm
guessing it has something to do with
everyone being in the same place in the
end now that I'm done uploading these a
plane on making another video where I
give all my thoughts on everything that
happened I will tell you what I liked
and what I didn't I will also tell you
how much of it I think could actually
happen next season but for now let's
just get into the video
the opening scene begins in Circe's
chambers jamie is still clutching
Circe's lifeless body in his arms there
are tears in his eyes and on his cheeks
he continues to hold her and look at her
Jamie gives Cersei another kiss on the
forehead then he carries her body and
lays her down on the bed daylight is
beginning to break through some of the
clouds as a light flurry of snow begins
to fall
Jamie wipes the tears off of his cheek
and out of his eyes then he begins to
make his way back outside when Jamie
exits the room he looks at Kai burns
dead body laying on the floor in a pool
of blood
as Jamie steps around the corner he is
startled by what he sees next euron
greyjoy is gone Jamie had knocked out
his teeth with his golden hand and drove
bronze dagger into his chest he left him
lay there to die but now he's not here
there are a few teeth in a small pool of
blood and the dagger is there - someone
must have took his body for some reason
or god forbid he is still alive and he
escaped the city as more and more light
comes through the clouds everyone can
see just how much destruction was caused
last night King's Landing looks like a
smoking ruins everything is burnt black
with smoke rising from piles of rubble
all over the city there are multiple
fires burning still from the dragons and
the Wildfire almost all of the Lannister
men are dead but some of them did choose
to lay down their arms in the face of
the Dragons all of the survivors are
looking around in disbelief they never
expected the capital to
like this the hound walks back up to the
top of the wall to see his brother some
of the wild fire is still burning around
the mountains body most of his armor is
melted into the stone there is nothing
left of the enormous man that was once
known as the mountain that rides no one
knew about the amount of wildfire Qyburn
had stashed down into cells because it
was so far below the ground the dragon
fire that torched most of the buildings
was never able to reach it and set it
all off Daenerys and John walk up to the
doors to the throne room and Daenerys
enters while John looks on from the
doors Daenerys is finally looking at the
iron throne she so desperately tried to
win back for her family's name now the
iron throne resides in a city that is
completely destroyed
Daenerys walks up to the throne and
looks at it for several moments but she
loses all interest to take a seat so she
walks back over to the doors when
Daenerys exits the throne room John asks
her what she plans on doing with it now
Daenerys says she wants it burned melt
the chair down King's Landing will no
longer be the capitol of Westeros
Daenerys said she wanted to break the
wheel entirely we have all sacrificed
too much for us to allow this vicious
cycle to continue we can't have one
person ruling all Seven Kingdoms while
they sit on the Iron Throne so John has
a few pots of wildfire brought into the
throne room they melt it down to the
ground into a puddle of liquid iron
everyone gathers back outside and they
all decide that they're gonna travel
back to the Trident first they lost a
lot of good men and friends on the
battlefield they want to give them a
proper burial they load everyone up on
the Dragons and they head for the
Trident when they get there it looks
even worse than when they left it tens
of thousands of bodies are laying in the
dirt and snow they begin walking through
all the dead bodies looking for loved
ones or close friends they eventually
come across Varys and kinvaras bodies
first both of them had been burn alive
during the battle most likely from
Viserion or so they hope so Daenerys
once Varys taken with them he stayed
loyal until the very end they also find
Jorah Mormont and barrack dawn
darienne's bodies next to each other
Daenerys begins to cry when
she sees her closest and oldest friend
laying dead in the snow jorah mormont
had died while he tried to stop a white
Walker from throwing its pier at
Daenerys and rogue on Daenerys says
Joris should be returned to Bear Island
to be with his family and they also
discovered torment and grey worm they
died during the attack on Winterfell but
they were turned into whites and they
were amongst the rest of the night
king's army their eyes are no longer
blue so they carry their bodies over to
the rest until they can decide how they
will lay them to rest as they are
walking across the battlefield everyone
stops when they hear wolves howl in the
distance Arya turns around and looks off
into the treeline there is a massive
pack of wolves watching them all after a
few moments Nymeria walks to the front
of her pack Aria and Nymeria look at
each other then Nymeria howls and the
rest of her pack begin to howl with her
Arya smiles as the pack disappears
amongst the trees
this makes Jon think of ghosts he hasn't
seen him since the night King attacked
Winterfell Jon tells everyone to start
to load up so they can head north
some of them volunteered to take the
bodies back to the ships Theon Han and
the others aboard the dragons to fly
back to Winterfell
after the dragons take off from the
trident the screen will go black for
several moments when the next scene
begins they will be in Winterfell in
several months have passed since the
last scene when Thor fell was still in
very bad shape the godswood were mostly
destroyed and the castle was burnt the
walls are badly damaged and crumbling in
several areas it will take a very long
time to rebuild most of the Seven
Kingdoms
Daenerys is visibly pregnant by this
time she is actually ready to give birth
any day now Jon and Daenerys have a long
talk about how they want to handle
things moving forward they hold a
meeting in the hall and they allow
everyone to voice their opinions with
how the Seven Kingdoms should be rein in
the future they all take a vote and
decide that each Kingdom should be
independent with its own Council to rule
over a certain amount of territory there
will no longer be one king or queen
ruling the kingdoms nor will there be
one person overseeing their own piece of
the kingdom they take another vote and
decide that Daenerys and John should
over
see everything together until Westeros
is stabilized again kingdoms and castles
need were built new crops need to be put
in place for harvest they will need to
vote on who will stand in as the first
set of councillors over each Kingdom
after they are restored
Gendry is legitimized as a Baratheon in
order to protect one of the major houses
of Westeros they offer Gendry his family
seat of power and they will help him
vote on a set of people to oversee that
area with them Gendry says he will stay
in Winterfell first until the north is
restored again Jaime and Tyrion are
offered their family seat in Casterly
Rock under the same terms both of them
volunteered to stay and help see the
other kingdoms restored first before
they go anywhere John tells his family
that once Winterfell was restored he
will be leaving and heading south what
Daenerys they're going to be raising
their child together on Dragonstone John
also tells them he wants to marry
Daenerys before she gives birth to their
child John 1 Sansa Arya and brain to
stay in Winterfell together unless they
want to leave they are free to do
whatever they please but he would hope
that a stark will remain in Winterfell
John and Daenerys will Wed in the
godswood in a few days even though the
Hartree is destroyed
Daenerys says she wouldn't mind a
traditionally northern wedding John will
go down into Winterfell scripts to see
his mother and Ned when John is down
there he will be reunited with ghost his
direwolf had fled the castle after
everyone escaped but he came back to the
empty castle and stayed down in the
crypts until everyone returned this will
be a very emotional scene for John he
will look at Leon a statue as his mother
for the first time and he will reunite
with his direwolf what she considered
could have been killed during the attack
Sansa and Brienne will have a discussion
about brianne's duties songs or reliefs
her of her vows she tells Brienne she is
free to go home if she would like
Brienne says that if Jaime is staying to
help then she will stay on a little bit
longer - Brienne and Jaime will both
offer their swords to Sansa Jaime says
ice should have never been melted down
into Lannister swords he gave his sword
to Brienne so she could find you and
your sister and keep you safe Jaime says
he has the other one and he's no longer
a competent swordsman anyway
the swords belong at the North with the
Starks sons it tells them both to hold
on to the swords while they are there
continuing to help Brian stark begins to
get very sick he is no longer having
visions and ever since the night King
was defeated he hasn't been feeling very
well he gets very weak and seldom leaves
his room now that brain Stark has served
the big purpose his powers are starting
to fade away in its weakening his entire
body it will be very similar to what
happened to Jojen Reed in season four
Theon and Yara both decide they will go
back to the Iron Islands
ever since Jamie said Euron's body was
missing from the red keep they fear
Euron could show up again and try to
start some kind of an uprising
Joran is badly wounded with no men our
fleet but he is still a very dangerous
man Theon and Yara set sail to the Iron
Islands with the few remaining Ironborn
men that lived Sam and Gilly are also
set to Wed Sam also wants to give little
Sam his last name Daenerys and John tell
them they can return to horn hel
whenever they want but they both
volunteer to stay in help before they go
anywhere the north took the most damage
since it was directly in the night Kings
path so they could use all the help they
can get the hound also decides to stay
in Winterfell for the time being in one
of the last scenes Daenerys goes into
labor Sam and Gilly both assist her
where they can Daenerys will give birth
to twins one boy with dark hair like
John's
and one girl was silver hair like
Danny's she will survive the pregnancy
in birth both babies are given the
Targaryen last name and after Daenerys
recovers and is able to leave they will
go back to Dragonstone to raise their
children the last scene will show the
last hearth in the cart hold being
rebuilt Winterfell will be almost
restored and most of the snow has melted
away in the far north there will be
people tending to their crops in people
building farms where they will keep
different animals the fishing villages
are lively again with different types of
fish getting packed into barrels of snow
and ice the people of Westeros are
trying to build a more civilized place
to live but will it last for long
all right folks that is the end of this
plot leak there are a few things I want
to say before I sign off first I just
want to say I did enjoy reading this and
seeing everyone's reaction to it
even if it is fake I still had some fun
doing this I also wanted to point
something out to some of you I noticed
some people leaving some comments on the
previous videos where they were voicing
their concerns because they felt the
plot leaked left out too many things and
in their mind that means it's all fake
well I just have to say that happens
with pretty much any plot lake you will
never find a plot league that has every
single detail it's just not possible I
don't know how many of you read the plot
leaked for season seven but that one
ended up being 100% accurate but it
didn't have very many details at all and
it left out tons of scenes it also
didn't add any context to most of the
things that it did have but with that
being said it was still accurate with
all the things that it did have so just
keep that in mind when you are wondering
why this one didn't mention this person
or this one didn't mention that person
just because it might not have mentioned
a certain character doesn't mean it's
all wrong go back and read this season 7
plot leaked and you will see it's all
correct but some of the episodes only
had one scene it might have left out
tons of details but what it did have was
true I also have to say I noticed some
of you saying it wasn't bitter enough to
be a bittersweet ending but I guess that
all depends on which characters you
value or how you see the series as a
whole when you think about all the great
characters that have died over the
course of this series and how families
and great houses were completely ripped
apart and gutted so many loved ones were
lost in major houses were reduced to
nothing all of Westeros had pretty much
turned into a battlefield with death all
around them if this what happened to be
true we would lose tormund grey worm
beric Dondarrion Jorah Mormont Varys the
Karstarks a numbers plus it looks like
bran stark is about to die and there are
no signs of the Starks producing an
error which means the stark named eyes
when Sansa and Arya do and I think that
would really suck but I still have to
say I do not believe all of this will
happen some red flags were raised while
I read certain things in this one which
I'll go over when I make that video I
think there are several things in these
episodes that will happen but there are
also some things that just don't seem
very likely in my opinion if you have
any questions about the plot Lee
leave them down below because a plane
don't answering some questions in the
next video - thank you all very much for
coming along on this ride with me even
if you think it's fake I hope you were
entertained in some way because at the
end of the day that is very important to
me - I also want to give a shout out to
all my wonderful patreon supporters some
of you have never wavered and I really
appreciate that have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]